[Musique]
c'est bon ça les pieds dans le sable et
les deux mains sur les téléphones telles
que la canne évangélistes enfants
camille gayet jongle ainsi depuis la
semaine dernière qu'a fait pierre côté
entre bandes dans ce centre commercial
lyonnais il est désormais impossible de
rentrer sans impasse sanitaires devant
chacune des 21 portes quatre hôtes
d'accueil filtrent les entrées avec
fermeté
pour le seront pour le temps
aujourd'hui 5 % des clients se sont fait
refouler faute de passe valide
il faut la deuxième dose c'en est fini
de la pédagogie
s'il vous plaît dans les restaurants les
forces de l'ordre ont pour consigne
depuis ce lundi de verbaliser en cas
d'infraction à l'heure du déjeuner dans
ce quartier très fréquenté les contrôles
du pass and it erp et des pièces
d'identité sanchez
une visite éclair qui ne dérange pas ce
client parce que ça nous rassure tous
pour rappel la menthe s'élève à 135
euros pour un client sans passé ni terre
ou disposant d'un qr code qui n'est pas
le sien et à 1000 euros pour le
responsable d'établissement qui
n'auraient pas effectué de contrôle huit
établissements ont été contrôlés par les
policiers 125 personnes aucune
infraction aucune contravention de
relever donc le message pédagogique de
la semaine dernière semble en tout cas à
produire ses effets comment vous vivez
la reprise le travail de ta part cpnt
compte en tant que marin tourner autre
pourquoi
vacciner toute la population en un temps
record tel était l'objectif de l'islande
pour atteindre l'humanité collective en
quelques mois plus de 75 % de ses
habitants ont été entièrement vacciner
même stratégie à malte 91% bien au
dessus du taux de vaccination en france
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment une déception que les
vaccins ne soit pas aussi efficace pour
limiter les infections
depuis mi-juillet les espoirs islandais
d'éradiquer le coc vide se sont évaporés
car le nombre de contaminations n'a
jamais été aussi haut les personnes
vaccinées mais positive du un unique
responsable le variant delta plus
contagieux mes chers compatriotes de
l'hexagone des autres mer et de
l'étranger je m'adresse à vous ce soir
alors que nous continuons à nous battre
contre le virus avec détermination et
que tout est fait pour que la relance
économique et sociale soit la plus forte
possible dans notre pays parce qu'à
quelques milliers de kilomètres d'ici un
tournant historique est à l'oeuvre en
afghanistan loin de nos frontières mais
avec des conséquences majeures pour
l'ensemble de communauté internationale
pour l'europe et pour la france l'image
d'un peuple qui veut fuir son pays des
centaines et des centaines d'afghans
envahissent le tarmac de l'aéroport de
kaboul dans l'espoir d'être évacués
il court vers un avion encore au sol il
faut partir à tout prix vaine tentative
de discipline et la ruée des afghans qui
fuient
l'aéroport est envahi et même les avions
sur le tarmac
sont pris d'assaut tous les vols sont
désormais annulée et l'aéroport fermé
mais les candidats à l'exil sont prêts à
tout pour fuir leur pays le peuple
afghan a le droit de vivre dans la
sécurité et le respect de chacun
les femmes afghanes ont le droit de
vivre dans la liberté et la dignité et
si le destin de l'afghanistan est entre
ses mains nous resterons fraternellement
aux côtés des afghanes des afghans en
soutenant la société civile afghane et
en faisant notre devoir de protection de
celles et ceux que nous pouvons protéger
plein
[Musique]
jadis
fric royal
c'est pour fêter notre tour ouais
[Musique]
voilà verte n'est cette définition vous
disent tout petit tout petit
[Musique]
vous ne chantez que des chanteurs morts
que les chanteurs ou presque
qui sont sur le point de vue mais à une
époque où on parle tellement de parité
ce serait équitable d'avoir aussi des
chanteuses morte j'attends nolwenn leroy
ça va pas tarder mireille mathieu s'est
j'aimerais bien de la voir
voici notre champion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous me permettez un fantasme
une fois dans ma vie ok
les applaudissements sont pour la nuit
des taupes leur pièce de théâtre salué
par la critique le spectacle est
entièrement écrit et joué en top ce qui
donne ceci
un peu comme un épisode de la famille
kardashian mais avec une espèce de
vermine légèrement supérieur aux usa à
12 ans lematin ch et même pas m'occuper
de vous tu vois pas à 6 non pas du tout
ah non tu sais pas quoi fait mais tu
sais répondre et ben consacre temps à
autre chose alors il ya des moments où
j'aimerais bien être fini pour avoir
plus d'attention autour de moi parce que
c'est vrai que moi j'aime bien être le
centre du monde est dangereux c'est très
compliqué tu brûles quoi c'était
complètement stupide je ferais fleuriste
cuverie le coup
[Rires]
on
détecte les fleuristes
avait jamais crache sur le fleurissement
il c'est génial la mer un furet personam
était fleuriste sais pas pourquoi il
avait un truc unique bon ils s'appellent
eux nos jeunes et j'en ai eu un avant de
dire oui pour me faire plaisir j'en ai
eu d'accord il s'appelait il s'appelait
je ne me souviens pas vraiment ce n'est
pas du nom de votre chien bat dominique
ça fait quelques temps ah oui c'est pour
ça voyons toi ça c'est génial vous
l'avez acheté sur la braderie elle a
l'air de la doré en plus un elle
s'appelle comment elle s'appelle granger
ganja et ben voyons